when you set out to make a movie it
doesn't happen
exactly the way you have it in your head
there is this exploration there is this
evolution there's this unfolding or
revealing of the material
depending on what you need from them
what side of the room you're on
what you're looking at you need
everybody to peak at the same time
here's what we're trying to do we're
trying to make strangers
feel something at the same time
if you talk to a production designer and
they're good
they're not talking to you about you
know how many we got to lay all the
subfloor we got to do this you know we
got how much pain it's going to take
they're not talking to you about that
they're talking to you about the feeling
they're talking about the thing that you
want to evoke
whether it's for real or whether it's
fake you have to have confidence because
human beings are they don't be led by
somebody who's like oh god i don't know
what do you guys think you know they
want somebody who's going to
definitively say here's what we're going
to do and this is going to be right and
so
it takes you 10 or 15 years to get
comfortable enough to just go
dude it's my way of highway
you're wrangling a circus that has to
over the course of a hundred days this
movie took 106 days to shoot
um dragon tattoo took 150 days to shoot
over those hundred plus days you need
everybody to peak
depending on what you need from them
what side of the room you're on
what you're looking at you need
everybody to peek at the same time
boom operator has to peek dolly grip has
to pee
camera operator has to peek actors have
to peak in the over the shoulder
you know you may have the most wonderful
actor in the world and you're just
seeing past their
ears and if they're doing this it's
incredibly distracting so you got to go
to
you know lawrence olivier by any other
name and go just hold still
while we get this you're you're you're
you're kind of
you're trying to get everybody to be on
the same page
everybody in the same movie everybody to
be in the same moment and that's
a lot of work that's what you're doing
you're sculpting
behavior over time and you're given a
very very finite
amount of patience that the audience has
for you to get
those ideas across and to think of it in
in that way it's not chinese checkers
it's not about okay well i did that i
did the over and now
no it's it's three-dimensional chess
it's
you know as i say to to most of the
actors that i work with
i don't want your best version
of this scene to mandate
how the scene gets cut i want the best
version of the story
to mandate where i am at any point in
the room
so you're going to have to be good if i
have 15
setups you're going to have to be good
50 at least 15 times
i wanted to ask david when you're
presented with a script with a
written story how do you start thinking
about turning it into a visual story
well look it's a i said it's a lot
and i don't know i don't have a better
answer it's a very
peculiar thing you know when when
because you have friends who are saying
hey read my script or
you know people kind of have brighter
friends who get lost and they
you know say hey would you take a look
at this and and it's a very different
thing than when you're reading a script
that you might
make you know when you're when you're
reading a script or something you might
make you have to turn off the phone and
you have to
you know get your ipad and you have to
like sit down and you have to
go into that thing of okay
netflix logo
and then then the thing starts and
you're sort of being you're some kind of
you're imagining it right which is a
very different thing than just reading
something
um so it's it's tricky i don't i
it you know it's not like my eyes don't
roll back my head
what do they mean by this is this is
this humorous is this the writer being
humorous here is this
something that's supposed to be a visual
you know and i start making my notes
but remember you know it takes two years
for me not for directors but it takes
you know me about a year and a half to
two years to make anything so
i've got to be able to remember that
saturday morning
when nobody interrupted me and i could
get through the script the first time
so i can kind of have an umbilical
connection to that so i can go oh that's
what was exciting about this
because you do forget you know when the
sun's going down and
the teamsters revolt
so you have to you have to be able to
access that
a friend of mine once he was directing
his first film and he and he called me
and he said how many
takes can i ask for and i said what do
you mean he said you know i'm
working with this actress and she's said
to me um
she's only going to give me six takes
and i said
you know as far as i'm concerned you ask
for whatever it is you need
you know i i've never it's never i've
never understood
it's not about the pres it's not about
an actor presenting their
work to 40 people around them it's about
you know it's the boom operator it's the
camera operator it's
you know can you can you tweak the light
better can you
can the person hit a mark better or can
they be in f you know there's so many
asp it's not just about the actor you
know
that's the focus um of of what you're
trying to get but it's
there's it's a ballet between so many
different people
and to me that's the thing is to make it
all coalesce make it all
look effortless it's all about taste
you know equipment equipment's easy you
know every time i see
kids who say well you know how am i how
am i going to make my movie unless i can
you know get hollywood to pay for it
it's like get an ipad
like you don't have an ip your parents
don't have an ipad like
someone you know has an ipad like go
make your movie
you know you can write on it you can
email that script around to your friends
you can
get them all to show up the same place
you can film with it you can edit with
it
there's no excuse well okay first of all
um
i tried to buy the book um and 20th
century fox bought it
and i remember thinking well that's that
and um
josh donon who became my agent who was
the
guy who was trying to buy the book with
me said you should go and you should
talk with laura ziskin because
lord's his skin is not fox it's not the
fox that
you had to deal with on alien i said
here's the two ways you can go you can
do the three million dollar version of
this movie and
make it on videotape and and make your
seditious little
sharp stick in somebody's eye who may
see it somebody
in some little tiny theater or maybe it
may go straight to dvd
or the real actress edition here is the
50 million version give or take and to
put movie stars in and get people to go
and and talk about you know this
anti-consumerist
rantings of a of a schizophrenic madman
so we we went off when we came back we
had a schedule
we had a budget we had a cast
we had storyboards and we had a script
and we said
here it is it was a we took out to
dinner we put this giant thing on the
table and we said here it is
it's 625 million dollars it's brad pitt
it's edward norton
and um you have three days let us know
here's what we're trying to do we're
trying to make strangers
feel something at the same time
so everything that you do
as you are defining what you're going to
do
is about making strangers feel something
all at the same time if you
if you if you talk to a production
designer
and they're good they're not talking to
you about
oh my god you have any idea how many
people it's going to take to come in
here and
you know how many we got to lay all the
sub floor we got to do this you know we
got
how much pain it's going to take they're
not talking to you about that they're
talking to you about the feeling
they're talking about the thing that you
want to evoke they're talking to you
about
well i don't think that benjamin at this
point in his life
should be living upstairs i think he
should be living downstairs and i think
the reason why is because
he has to be living with the help he
can't so you have those kinds of
discussions
all everything that you're you know when
you're talking to
trent rezner and atticus ross you're not
talking about
use this synthesizer or this drum
machine or whatever you're talking about
i need a feeling happening here i want
you know with this movie the thing that
i said to him when i showed him was
i want spa music i want that kind of i
want your version
because he can't do anything like
anybody else he's gonna
make it trent rezner um i want your
version of
the kind of music that they play when
you get a massage you know it's always
supposed to be this music that kind of
calms you and lets you know everything's
gonna be okay give that to trent reznor
and atticus ross and see what they come
back with and and you end up with
something that makes you go
you know it sounds like it just sounds
like the hair standing up in the back of
your neck
but it still has this idea behind it
because the idea is the important thing
so when you when you go when you go to a
crew you turn to 90 people
you know and and you have all these
faces sort of looking at you like what
do you want to do next
um which is a terrifying thing because
you have to have
whether you whether it's for real or
whether it's fake you have to have
confidence because
um human beings are they don't be led by
somebody who's like oh god i don't know
what do you guys think you know they
want somebody who's going to
definitively say here's what we're going
to do and this is going to be righteous
and god-fearing and
that's the way it has to be and and so
it takes you
10 or 15 years to get comfortable enough
to just go
dude it's my way the highway you know
you you have to
you have to be able to do that and and
so i've
spent i mean it's probably what was
until i was 40 that i could kind of go
here's what we're doing here's exactly
what we're doing here's all i want
and and and mean it and people would
sort of
go right away i think that we are in a
really really interesting time
where we're sitting on the fence between
television
and film and if we play our cards right
you can build a whole new backyard and
there's no reason
for you know there are so many kind of
techniques that have been
inherited from both disciplines
that don't necessarily apply to
storytelling in the 21st century you
know we just
we don't read newspapers to say hey we
used to
why would we watch television the same
way that we used why would we go
to a theater and and and
be aware of act breaks and
you know here comes the complicator and
now we're in the third act now they've
got to tell me
you know i don't like sign posting i
want to be
lost i want to be inside a story we have
episodes
um in the season that unbeknownst to me
are 34 minutes long so
you know it's that thing when you kind
of cut it all and you get the
shape that you want it slides one way or
another
and there shouldn't be this sort of
metronomic
you know pavlovian here's where we are
in the story so many movies i feel like
i can
you know i i know when they're gonna
remind me of
what the big point is and third act i
know when they're you know i can feel it
you can feel all the
all the buttons being pushed and the
lever's being pulled and i like the idea
of creating cinematic
stories that don't
you don't know where you want the words
you're known for being
very precise in your directing
um somebody else was known for her his
precision
was alfred hitchcock was also a master
of suspense
but he was also meticulous in his
preparations
how meticulous are you in your prepping
i i try to be i mean i try to kind of
um take everything that can go wrong
into account because something's going
to go wrong
on on any given day um but i don't also
want to overthink something to the point
where it's just
uh becomes sort of boring execution
or you know checking off a list um i
wanted to be
communal and i want it to be and i want
people to have an investment i want
the actors and the cinematographer and
the dolly grab
and i want people to be invested in
coming up with ways to make things more
concise anybody who knows anything about
movies knows that when a movie works
it's usually luck
you know it's calculated you know you're
you're
you're trying to elicit a certain
response but you're when it
when it really happens it's it's a
confluence of so many
um
you know different career paths all
crossing over at exactly the right
moment
you